hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the super bat rapid and blitz
tournament this is the second day of the
rapids after three day of blitz koruba
was leading the tournament and then
after the first day of boot scorable was
again leading the tournament and now we
are at the final day again the blitz
section and now he faces Vishwanathan
Anand now in the rapid rapid section
Korra was able to beat Anand in a very
nice attacking game so here it's gonna
be very interesting to see what happens
and if Korra both can maintain maintain
his lead so basically without further
ado I do hope you enjoyed this game as
it features well the title basically
says it all so let's check it out and
the two of them will be repeating a game
they've already played in 2018 in some
computer work in the world blitz
championship so let's see who prepared
1.e4 by Anand we have see five bike or
above the Sicilian defense Knight of
three b6 and the d4 captures captures we
have a knight to f6 Knight to c3 and of
course the knight of variation is on the
board Bishop to e3 we have E 5 pushing
the knight back night the b3 is the most
common move but Anand prefers Knight to
f3 we have Queen to c7 and now a for
taking away the b phi square from black
so b5 is not another option at the
moment with h6 by horrible and now
Bishop to e2 Anand is now ready to cast
with Bishop to e6 and castles by Anand
with Bishop to e7 horrible also prepares
the castle and now a5 grabbing more
space on the Queen side with Bishop to
b6 in mind if well if it's gonna be
useful at some point so Knight B to d7
guarding the b6 square for now also
developing the night and Knight to d5
now with Knight captures the Queen on c7
is under attack so you have to react to
this Knight captures with pawn captures
and Bishop to f5 here Cora Bob is
attacking the sea dew points so on and
advances it to c4 where it's nicely
protected
we have castles bike or above and now b4
by Anand and two of them already reached
this exact same position last year in
the world blitz championship in st.
Petersburg
and Bishop h7 is the mood at kora both
place now but in that game rook a to c8
was played in the world with
championship and the dead game ended in
a draw so better up to h7 core above
deviates from the line the two of them
played now prepares f5 it's not a new
move it's been played before but here
it's Anand who plays a new move now here
look 8 the c1 is a known move Knight the
d2 is a normal night the e1 is a known
move but here we have Queen to b3 so it
is as a move 16 that we have a
completely new game on our hands
so let's see what happens with f5 core
above continues to advance on the Kings
side maybe maybe with ideas of pushing
f4 maybe even efore we have c5 by Anand
and now kink the h8 as you don't want
your King on the same diagonal as the
Queen so King to h8 and now rook a to C
1 D captures on c5 with B captors on c5
and now the c5 pawn is guarded twice and
it's attacked three times so can the
court above capture the pawn well the
short answer is no but horrible
nevertheless captures it he plays Knight
captures on c5 and now for some reason
on and the dislikes the rook captures
and see if I look at verse on c5 just
grabs two pieces for a rook after this
of capers and rook a to c1
there is no good way there's no good way
to guard the bishop here it's it's not
possible you could try something like b6
and claim that you are actually
defending it but after eight captures
and Queen captures the bishop is still
under attack twice oh just Queen
captures and b6 and we'll pick up Bishop
so you're gonna end up the variation
having a bishop and the night for sorry
something is wrong with the colors the
bishop in a knight for a rook with a
winning position so on and for some
reason doesn't like this he goes for a
more well more quiet idea I mean maybe
it's because of it's a blitz game so he
goes Queen to c3 now adds a third
attacker to the night while also
attacking the e5 pawn twice with the
Queen and the night
so rook 8se 8-core above defense denied
and now Knight captures on e5 grabbing
that a five pawn and now this is a very
dangerous pass point if you can start
pushing it probably why I decided to go
for this maybe he didn't want to over
calculate it it is ability the game
after all
so Queen to d8 going after the d5 pawn
and now rook F to d1 defending the d5
pawn with f4 further advancing the point
but now Bishop to d4 now the bishop
queen battery after the knight moves
will have some threats against the g7
pawn bishop the f5 by Horeb of making a
room for the King on h7 and now comes
Knight back the c-4 opening up an attack
on the g7 pawn bishop to f6 defending
and now Bishop captures on f6 and here
cordova doesn't like Queen captures on
f6 a problem with Queen captures and f6
is that after Queen captures you you
have to mess up your pawn structure and
you're just gonna have a bad end game
because if you go rook captures if you
don't want to mess up your pawn
structure then you get Knights to be six
and now this rook will just be
overloaded the the pawn will start
advancing there's not all that much you
can do here for example if you move the
rook rook c7 just b6 if you move it Roxy
six then you get Bishop to f3 attacking
the rook the rook has nowhere to go
let's say Bishop here you don't trade
like this you trade with rook captures
on c5 and now it's just a completely
winning position for white you could go
get some captures on f3 but now d7
preparing b8 the Queen and after Luke
and faith you can just queen and that's
sufficient for a win you have a well
after you trade down you have a young
Gustavson a type of endgame where one
player is up a whole rook
so after Bishop captures and have six
core above tries to keep everything
together he plays the rook captures and
f6 he he doesn't want to trade Queens
but still nice to b6
as it is an excellent tapas for the
knight threatens the rook here so rook
the c7 and now Queen to b4 now
threatening rook captures night so
Knight the e4 saving right also offering
a trade of rooks on c7 and now
Bishop to f3 by Anand with a double
attack on the night here so night back
to d6 bike or above and now rogue back
to e 1 hero core buff takes his chance
and well trades a proxy with rook
captures rook captures and the bishop
back to g6 now and here on and sees that
ok now this and this diagonal is
available for my bishops mom I'm gonna
play Bishop g4 also you have to be very
careful a lot of pieces are guarding
that c8 square for example if the knight
moves rook C it is just deadly so here
best for Cordoba was just Bishop to 5
but it's always hard it doesn't matter
how strong you are it's always hard to
admit that your previous move was a was
a was a poor choice because here you
just have to trade down into into this
game where you will be down upon the
ship captures Queen characterís white is
up upon and it's it's a very strong past
D pawn so instead the core above just
plays came to h7 he gets the King away
from the from the last rank and the now
comes the Knight to d7 by Anand
threatening the rook on f6 and core
above goes Knight to e4 he says okay I'm
gonna give up the exchange and maybe
maybe I can create some chances you know
as I always Corbeau is always able to
wiggle out from any position so maybe
this is one such position but Anand says
nope this is not one such position so
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out why this is not one such
position and well how do you win this
game for white the easiest possible way
and the quickest one so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on paying attention to the title of the
video and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's rook to c8 and
that's it
the queen is trapped the Queen has no
squares you cannot capture the knight
the bishop obviously well guards the
night you cannot go to e7 as the Queen
covers the e7 square and lastly but of
course not leastly
queen cat person c8 loses the night
captures on f6 with check now and this
opens up a discovery to the Queen so
here you would just have to capture it
and then after this captures you are
down Queen
you do grab the d5 pawn but it's uh it's
you know it's not even a consolation
prize it's completely winning for white
so after rook to c8 core above realizes
that his Queens just trapped and that's
that's it Anand wins wins the game
so excellent game by Anand excellent
retaliation even though he didn't go for
that rook c5 idea he went for more
positional approach but in the end
everything worked out so yeah I'm not
gonna mention the standings but I will
mention that you know the the Blitz
section has not been kind to Anton
horrible who went into the final day
leading the tournament but as we're
gonna show more games from the from the
final day we're gonna check out the
standings then yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Andrew Wilson and whitbeck
Holdings LLC for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon
continuing the coverage of the Frieda
Graham pre well of the superb at rapid
tournament along start with the feeder
Grand Prix we've been neglecting that
one for a few days but we will we will
get back to it and not no worries
so thank you thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your day